[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo Freunde und Willkommen zu catch Mr
Troll Part 10 zusammen mit gömmchen
hdchen MC gomme hi moin ich beneide dich
echt so für dieses Schwert was ich
irgendwann mal verloren habe es ist so
traurig dit kann ich dir der Nase pul
guck mal mach mal5 mach mal5 sieht mal
das von dir warte nein jetzt nicht jetzt
warte ich muss mich wieder so ey du
könntest das theoretisch mal guck mal
Nein durch mich durchhalten warte ich
sehe es leider nicht von vorne se leider
[Gelächter]
nicht so durch und das passt do einfach
mit dem Kopf den du aufhast so ne das B
nicht unbedingt du das ist der Typ der
so ein
plastik
hat
oh ja gut die ersten Z Minuten sind d
schon mal damit
beschäftigt alle schon direkt wieder
abgeschaltet oh nee nicht schon wieder
so stell mal vor Leute haben so gerade
eingeschaltet W dann hab so mot Kot
Kannen uns doch gar nicht sonst ja dann
ja ich hab Feuer voll Profis gehalten so
was steht denn hier alles gesagt okay
komm ich gucke jetzt mal ein paar Folgen
nicht dann schalten sie wieder ein und
dann sehen die das einfach oh Mann gut
aber wir haben in der letzten Folge hier
so ein Gewissen Parkour ich habe noch
ein netherstern gefunden e guck mal g
komm mal hier rum schau mal hier hier
schon wieder so ich find immer diese
dummen Kisten und GME findet immer die
wichtigen GME findet ein Schalter ich
find ein Nestern allein diese Tatsache
dass ich acht habe und GME 3 ist auch
schon hast du das Buch schon vorgelesen
was jo heißt ich hab schon
[Musik]
wo müssen wir jetzt lang
er okay wir
habenen
gen ein Schalter mit dem wir zurück Z
Buddha teleportiert werden wir machen
erstmal fire Kingdom vielleicht sogar
ganz gut dass ich uns
dieses okay bist auch da ich bin ich bin
jetzt da
Jale breaking
down was du Aura gebaut hast obwohl du
hast dra gebaut ne ja ja das sieht so
ein bisschen obwohl der ist noch also
ich bin noch nicht
fertig bin gespannt ob ich damit auch
fertig W noch mal gut aussieht e hier
ist eine Zeitmaschine lOL wie warte wir
haben den Schal falsch Schalter g nicht
gedrückt und jetzt
h wo bist du bin nemen dir du bist ah
lol hi ja es ist glaube ich quasi so
gemacht dass wenn man auf diese Platte
drauf drückt über diese Platte drüber
läuft siehst du die dann wird man
teleportiert ach ne wir ja und mit dem
Schal Schalter funktioniert eigentlich
gar nichts also das ist qu einfach nur
du läuf quasi drüber und denkst du dass
es damit funktioniert aber letztendlich
macht der Schalter nur dass diese W sich
bisschen verändert oder so keine Ahnung
wir sind auf jeden Fall hier so alles
gut und endlich mal wieder Nahrung guck
mal in die Truhe er guckt nicht in die
Truhe Alter einfach nur drei
äpfelus ohne ohne Nahrung ohne dass ich
mir diese ganze Zeit gebratene Schnitzel
geholt hätte ne hätten wir es echt nicht
geschafft mit sprinten und so also
Nahrung war echt ein Problem Checkpoint
manchmal aber an sich sowas wie das
jetzt aufgebaut ist extrem cool guck dir
das an sieht echt episch aus sieht echt
episch aus at least Castle not g crush
us anymore by the jetzt kan ich nicht
[Musik]
mehr one hard Jump H geht doch voll
können theoretisch sogar hier
runterlfen do you know the meaning of
insanity ja das ist sehr in wo bist du
hinter dir nice das ist sehr sehr stark
sehr sehr krass was springen wir
eigentlich in eine falsche Richtung weil
wir irend gerade nach unten
springen mal schauen nee doch richtig
okayck bist du da bin da nö oh
ne oh ne
ne rette sich ich geschafft geschafft
ich halte mal gedrückt für dich
Abonnenten und Minecraft Freunde
zuerst
Checkpoint okay habe ich
gedrücktol ich hab geschafft okay gut
der Check funktioniert wieder
nicht echt ges Folge und auch meiner
Folge manchmal die Probleme ein
Checkpoint ja gut das ist aber
vielleicht auch der Troll an der Sache
so weißt du von MR Troll aufgebaut die
Karte und wir spielen halt einfach nur
Troll Maps oder irgendwie schon und
nicht klappt aber es ist einfach wenn
was nicht klappt das ist ein Troll V
mapersteller ist immer so Jump Boost Bro
oh lol ich habe schon wieder so viel
Sprungkraft Alter du machst diese Teile
auch einfach nicht auf
ne
n
irgendwie gar nicht schwer so oh der
Checkpoint hat
geklappt Respekt hätte ich nicht gedacht
komm zu mir hat geklappt hätte ich nicht
gedacht Gluck wo ich bin guck mal guck
mal nach links hallo nach links e J du
Pisser oh
mann du bist
Arsch troller lol ja nich troller lol
kriegst alles noch Z und dann Nann mich
Arsch derum
Bars dumme Barsch Freunde ihr seht schon
ne wenn wir irgendwann mal wenn der kom
mal V oder in so Rap Battle teilnehmen
würde W ein nach jedem dis jetzt warte
er mein Teil ab jaorevor du jetzt
irgendwas vorwegnimmst Teil du darfst da
nicht so viel
verraten wie soll man denn sonst
zusammen ein ein Rap machen ja stimmt
okay das ist B hast recht ohol ich hab
es geschafft ich glaube wenn g VBT
teilnehmen würde was ich von sagen
wollte würde einfach so nach jedem nach
jeder Lein von ihm einfach selbst über
diese Lein lachen weil er die so gut
fand ja man wo bist du eigentlich
gerade ja nicht mehr das war die Rache
wenn du mich jetzt runter kckst wär es
echt traurig weil ich gerade fast
geschafft hab e lass es
doch habe ich getroffen ja du hast mich
getroffen aber ich bin nicht
runtergefallen Alter aber du sehen
müssen wie ich dich getroffen hab so im
Sterben das war richtig cool ach da eben
gerade hast mich nicht getroffen oh m da
muss ich dir aber deine Illusion nehmen
okay wo muss ich denn jetzt lang
springen h und Du bist wieder da unten
jofe
checkun
e wo bist du ah hier war ich ja auch
schon mus dann wurde ich irgendwie
runtergeschossen da musst du nicht
runter safe klar weil an sich springst
ja nur gleich wieder hoch
ne ich kürze mal wenig ab
Moment so macht man das doch wir hätten
da stimmt nicht das war echt unsinnig
und ich habe mein Jump auch nicht mehr
aber ich glaub den braucht man gerade
auch
nicht doch ja gut doch ja genau hier
braucht man den wieder ach jetzt brauche
ich Jump Boost oder
kommme ich hoffe dass du schaffst ich
bin auch wieder nur gestorben weil du
mich runtergekickt hast obwohl das nur
meine Rache war ja tut mir leid tut mir
leid komm
hoch oh oh schon wieder
nicht nur an mit de ich bring mich jetzt
um ich kann mich nicht umbringen bei
meiner
Rüstung ohne Witz man kann ja irgendwie
be solche
ressourcenacks ziemlich gut Gesichter
oder keineung gesichterinbekommen est du
theoretisch vielleicht auf dein Skin
deinen echten Kopf draauf machen dass da
wirklich erkennbar ist fr ich
michadehr hochlösend ja ja also wenn
wenn das gehen würde das wä so lustig
wenn du einfach in deem Skin dein Kopf
drinest W so
lustig übelst
geben einfach dein echten Kopf drin ich
komme hier wieder nicht weiter das ist
immer richtig traurig glaub ich hol mir
jetztfach mal dies Jump sonst muss das
alles normal machen ich H kurzump
SP Jump ne wie heißt das
dennftur Block was J
stimmt ja na
toll das heißt entweder ich ma alles
normal oder ich teleporti michim zur
GME und
guck concentrate oh hier steht
concentrate
okay hier sind unsichtbare Blöcke
geschafft du hast ja auch die
Sprungkraft
e aber du machst das spitze kom
mal ich habe halt ich habe nichts
gemacht ich habe nichts gemacht ich
schwöre ich war nicht habe extra daneben
geschossen das sieht man
auch ich
schwöre m ich schwöre komme wo bekomme
ich jetzt Sprungkraft von hier oder was
ne wir müssen jetzt wieder hoch verdamt
oh mann das ist traurig komm jetzt wir
schaffen das jetzt eben zusammen komm
mit das kann jetzt nicht so lange dauern
das schaffen wir jetzt eben das ist aber
voll der lange Teil der Karte ja egal
wir schaffen das jetzt so wir sind jetzt
wieder hier bei concentrate den ganzen
Rest hatten wir ja schon geschafft
deswegen hab jetzt gedacht wir gehen hin
ich habe sprungra 4 der G hat es auch
und jetzt wo bist du lang ich bin auf
die fckel ich schaff wieder nicht ich
bin wieder tot e was für eine Kacke ich
hasse
wio wie kann ich diesen Sprung nicht
schaffen sag mal hast du keine Rüstung
mehr oder oder w ich hab gar keine
Rüstung ne nee ich habe noch rung übrig
ich habe noch ein Helm und eine Hose für
dich vielleicht hilft Dir das ein wenig
ich habe auch nur Helm und
Hose aber ich schaff es jetzt ne
letendlich ich laufe jetzt hier eben
lang oder du kommst zu mir ich bin ja
schon weiter ja komm wir sind ja ein
Team ich komme jetzt eben zu dir TP HD
hallo hallöchen so und jetzt jetzt muss
ich auf den Block
drauf ist auch scheiße mit diesen komm
zu mir ist aber eine Kacke mit diesen
durchsichtigen
Kacke bist du bei mir ich habe nein ich
habe keine Sprungkraft mehr ich hab den
Sprung geschafft
ja okay auch gescha jetzt tauschen wir
die Rollen oder was ich habe keine
Sprungkraft mehr nein ja ich schaff
jetzt schafft geschafft geschafft
geschafft warte warte warte lieber ich
hole mir schnell Sprungkraft dann kann
ich dich ablösen an der
Stelle locker warte warte warte warte so
Sprungkraft habe ich auch wieder ang
nicht schaff jetzt jetzti dir so jetzt
kannst Du in Ruhe weitermachen ich
schaff das jetzt
locker kein Ding hier mehr für
King locker eilig der Junge hat
eilig eben durch mein Gott die gehen
wier kein Ding für King das war bei mir
hier das ist auch diese Map ne ist schon
gar nicht mehr witzig die da Wein ich
echt immer wenn
ich
geschafftit for the castle load before
continue ja ne look down the castle den
up the castle toll Baby ja es ist echt
riesig wo bist jetzt Klick auf die geh
auf die Druckplatte soll ich da auch auf
gehen oder soll ich
weiterpringen guck mal ja guck mal was
was mir aufgefallen ist wo bist du denn
bin noch da oben ich bin weiter
gesprungen ich bin hier oben guck mal ja
das ist mir nämlich auch schon
aufgefallen die wir s diese ganzen
Sprünge gesprungen und letztendlich geht
sogar hier hoch
einfach gestendwo wir müssen da lang
springen ich glaube nicht
trollolol ich glaube wir wir müssen du
musst hier unten lang gibt ah hier kann
man skippen wenn man möchte okay nee ich
habe da nur Schaden bekommen irgendwie
ach so so als Bestrafung gibt's keins
okay wie machen wir jetzt weiter aber
ich denke wir brauchen noch Jump Boost
oder also sonst komm nicht hoch ich habe
den auch noch ach du hast den noch D
muss ich wieder auf dich ich hab
ST das ist doch hier das kannst nicht
mehr
sein immer bekommst du diese
nesserstars das war's aber auch wieder
mit dieser Folge sehr sehr chaotisch
aber wir haben letlich g merkwürdig so
of bei Folgen passiert irgendwas
chaotisches das ist unvorstellbar oder
das mit den squids oder ach mann ja gut
Leute wenn es euch gefallen hat zeigt es
uns mit einer Bewertung und die nächste
Folge kommt morgen bei gomme und dann
holen wir uns den Schalter Nummer 1 für
den Palast von MR Troll den wir dann
besiegen werden tschüss schön